it's February which as we all know is
Black History Month and if it's okay
with you I'd like to take a moment to
highlight
well the accomplishments of my
african-american brothers and sisters
you see we all know that dr. Martin
Luther King Jr's vision for America
called for racial justice and sadly we
seem to be drifting further and further
from the dream dr. King so eloquently
set forth back in 1963 you see the way I
stand hand in hand with African
Americans all over this land you have to
think to you Wow
it's a nerve of Konan today is February
28 clearly he waited for the last
possible moment to acknowledge Black
History Month was in 27 minutes left in
February and suddenly he's friends with
all black people this from a guy who
makes Blake Shelton look like gucci mane
he thinks beyonce is pronounce bay once
conan once told me his favorite rapper
is dr. Scholl's
I heard he turns on all the lights in
his house before he watches blackish you
know does he know about black culture
Coenen thought Tavis Smiley was a black
emoji the thought Jordan Peele was a
middle-eastern skin treatment Horan
thought Condoleezza Rice was a Cajun
side dish look at pandering to the crowd
I bet he makes a reference to the Black
Panther movie and I think we can all
agree that the Black Panther is the kind
of movie we need in these troubled times
until last week Coenen thought Wakanda
was a yoga pose keep talking Conan
if you fainted in a grocery store you'd
wake up on the Shelf with the rest of
the crackers
thank you go
I love the band because they have my
back
you